it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we get the vigilante aidan
who's stopping crime in a unique way and
I'm not talking about that tire iron
watchdogs comes to old and current-gen
as well as PC so you can serve justice
to all the criminals of Chicago but as
they'll say on the evening news who
makes this guy judge and jury and who's
watching the watchdog's is it another
dog is it you watching a dog watch watch
dogs start hacking may 27 also this week
we get the long-running series of armed
and vertebrae's with worms battlegrounds
those poor worms have been in war for so
long they've invented ten new items to
kill each other including the mega
mortar and the whoopee cushion but rest
assured that they didn't nerf the sheep
attack comes to Europe May thirtieth
America gets a July third next up is a
game with a visual style of limbo and a
gameplay mechanic reminiscent of Eiko
it's called mono chroma and it's a
cinematic platformer where you solve
various puzzles while protecting your
helpless little brother to avoid this
creepy guy who kind of looks like a
member of nambla through an industrial
world the perfect mix of creepy and
good-looking protect your bro may 28 now
this week's actually got a few games for
the color blind as kill the bad guy
comes out on pc
perfect for the person who doesn't want
to just kill the bad guy but kill him
kill him good run him down cut off his
head and burn the remains fun for the
whole family serve out more vigilante
justice may 28 and finally power slide
your way to victory with Mario Kart 8
it's awesome I hope you're really
excited about the gorgeous tracks and
the smooth race cars and the tight
controls because you'll need to hold on
to that happiness when you find out that
battle mode is a holy garbage dump of a
gameplay mode whatever happened to the
if it ain't broke don't fix it mantra
Nintendo how can I steal balloons
effectively on a racetrack Nintendo but
the race mode is still loads of fun and
you already have that wii u so just pick
it up from a 30th also the wolf among us
episode 4 comes out on the
twenty-seventh but i can't show any of
it because spoilers for further details
visit gamespot's new releases page
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week
you